we are currently being joined by miss
Cathy Kennedy Luna Alan Tudyk
Donnie Yen and John Knoll so we've
talked quite a bit about how you've been
a Star Wars fan pretty much your whole
life so the lead-up to rogue one has
been a pretty long road now the people
are seeing the movie and you're getting
feedback how do you feel estranged
obviously it's it's it's this is a very
strange period in making a film this
this little moment here because for it
for about two and a half years you're
really busy making it and your heads
down and you can't really think of
anything else and now we finished the
movie but we haven't released it I feel
like we're a little bit pregnant and
we're you know the due day is we're just
ready to give birth and let's share it
with the world it's it's yeah it's it's
um it's it's kind of frustrating in a
weird way to not be able to just show
you all the movie now because the cast
got to see it for the first time two
days ago and let him speak about it but
it went down very well I think hi could
you just talk about in finding this
character was it all on the script or
did you go back and look at other Star
Wars films to sort of figure out where
your kind of character fits into the
hierarchy or was it just all there for
you once you certainly were to read the
story it was a mixture of everything but
at the beginning yes I started just with
the script that was already interesting
enough for me to kind of dig into myself
and try to find these these these
captain inside me and I guess the most
important part was to do the military
training you know you have to establish
a parallel to you know with this galaxy
far far away and and the world you live
in and and it was very interesting to be
I spent two weeks with
ex-military in in in London just talking
about experiences and about the last ten
or fifteen years of his life and and
that gave me enough material and then I
mean I love Star Wars and and I love the
films and a new hope is probably the
first film I I really connected with so
I would go back to to that film to find
that connection again but it was more
about seeing war films you know
Apocalypse Now for example stuff like
that because my character is he needs
that kind of military structure and and
this is the it's a guy that is willing
to risk anything for this cause you know
but but he he thinks in a dur article
kind of structure and and and he has to
start there at least in this film so
yeah that was the research I did hi guys
Lucas eagle from comic book calm Donnie
I have a question for you I'm right up
front here Donnie I have a question for
you Donnie how much of the obviously the
force is very much derived from Eastern
philosophy how much of your study of
martial arts helped you develop your
relationship with the force as cheered
in way oh that's that's a good question
but I never thought about relating to
the martial arts you know I always think
of the force we all have to force it's
just we don't realize it it's kind of
it's kind of like it's kind of like I
think it's interesting to see to me
Star Wars story is about reminding us
that thinks that we need to let and
forget and the force is resolved we
always have these kind of bility and to
answer your question is I don't think of
it as having the martial arts ability
it's just being a human being you do
have to force question Agartha it's been
revealed that George Lucas came to the
set of this what's it like to have
George on set and does he has he seen
any footage
what does he have plans to see can I so
two days ago we got to show George the
movie and we all had a phone call and I
got to speak with him yesterday and I
don't want to put words into his mouth
but I can honestly say that I can die
happy now he really liked the movie so
it meant a lot to be honest and no
offense to anyone here it was the most
important review to me was what George
thought of it you know you guys are
important too but come on he's kind of
God when it comes to Star Wars what's
that yeah it was we're in the middle of
doing press and and you know yeah you
know you have one interview another
interview and then suddenly they said we
need to take a break and I was like I'm
okay
there's like no we need to take a break
and then we go they go we need to talk
to you we gonna just go out the room and
it's like what's going on something
Bad's happened and we're going to room
they say George wants to speak to you
and they made the call and I was like
and yeah and I will take that
conversation to my grave it was it was a
real privilege and he you know his
opinion means the world to me so and and
John and Kathy have spoke to him say
it's yeah hi I'm Maggie Lyons from Amy
Poehler's Smart Girls back here this is
a question for Cathy sort of a follow up
on the last question in terms of women
specifically in Jenner so what do you
think the future of women in star wars
could mean for women in media and the
world at large and why is it important
to you - well first of all I hope it has
that level of impact that would be great
you know I think it is really important
I you know I found it really interesting
when I first stepped into this job and I
started to look at you know what does it
mean to be a female hero a female
heroine and when you started to look
certainly online at imagery it was
pretty shocking what came up
and I think the character of Rey the
character of Jin I think these are
empowered women that are not necessarily
just taking on male characteristics
there are genuinely female heroines and
I think that's really important to the
way we tell stories and so I do hope
you're right I think it will make a
difference thank you Jerome made a photo
feed Billy News I have a two-part
question once for Garth I just want to
say from the footage I saw tremendous
accomplishment what was your challenge
you think because the tone and this is
so much different from other Star Wars
films it's more a war movie and heist
movie as they say and how you have that
different tone so you get something
different but still feel like Star Wars
what's a challenge with that and for
Kathy you know you know follow up like
in question a lot of people ask is you
know one of the things that slightly
annoys me when people bring up oh you
have a female lead it's as if we've
never had a strong female character
before you know from Betty Davis
- Katniss Everdeen there's been a lot of
strong female characters which you know
how do you feel about that and how do
you feel that I just feel that what I've
seen she has an opportunity to be one of
the most memorable characters period
that we've seen yeah the time was I mean
we essentially got a license to be
different on this movie and take a risk
you know the great thing about being a
standalone film we don't really have to
exist for other movies to continue etc
and so we could be brave and that's what
we did and I feel like in terms of Star
Wars is that you know that I love
tonally I guess the one we were like you
know aiming for was something like
Empire Strikes Back where our movie even
though it's we take it quite seriously
there's a lot of fun and humor in it and
and hope you know is the key thing is
that it's it's about trying to achieve
something I mean the the story really
behind the movie is like all these
different people from all these
different backgrounds that have very
little in common if they
believe in a good you know future for
the world they come together and and and
we all are better off when we work
together than than on our own and and so
we just tried to make the most realistic
version of Star Wars that we had seen
and and involves a lot of different
techniques but I can t remember Kathy's
question you can remember it so mm-hmm I
think you're absolutely right I I find
that it is a bit irritating that when
there's progress being made and strong
female characters being created it tends
to be forgotten and I think that's
because long periods of time go on in
between but I think it speaks to what
what I was talking about before which is
these are big tent pole so it frankly
male-driven boy driven kinds of
entertainment in the past and that's why
I was saying that I think the idea of a
female hero is what's new I think that
heroine concept is what's been lacking
and I think in this movie the irony is
she's not as you say necessarily just a
female hero she's just a very strong
wonderful character in a movie and to
highlight that as being something
specific to being a woman I I think that
that that's what I hope disappears over
time that we're not constantly
highlighting this as though it's
something unusual but that it actually
just becomes the vernacular of
storytelling my name is Brian yang I'm
asking about the footage last night
there seemed to be a moral complexity to
the universe there whether that's
casseon doing things that maybe aren't
the most heroic
but or even all the the toy packaging
for k2s oh says that maybe he's trying
to make up for something I mean he is an
imperial droid I'm wondering if all of
you could kind of speak to that moral
gray area where Star Wars before always
seem to be very black-and-white about
heroes and villains Diego yeah I think
it I think it's and it connects with
hello
it's like censorship I think it's it's a
modern approach to Star Wars and we live
in a different world today
you know I said if you revisit all the
films it's kind of like a stamp of what
was going on and a reflection on the
world back then you know and ours has to
do the same and we live in a diverse
diverse world where racial and cultural
diversity is is in fact making us richer
and more interesting and but it is a
complex world we live in and making the
right choice many times looks horrible
you know and and this these people are
in war you know when you when you
mention casseon doing something not
heroic I would say now casseon is it's a
true hero as Jane and everyone in this
team you know it's just that they are
the heroes we can be just regular people
doing amazing stuff you know and no
special powers no Jedi is no it's just
conviction and and teamwork and and and
yeah that that hope of actually being
able to shape the reality we live in and
that makes them great you know but yes
they have to make choices on the way and
war is horrible I mean no one wants were
to happen none of these characters would
choose for you know but it's the last
the last chance you know and they have
to do it so a lot of people think that
the k2 is is strictly CG but you were
actually on set in
like a mocap suit yes yes what's that
performance like what was it like being
on set with everyone who was in
character and you're kind of removed
from it I got it I got this Diego Diego
was very funny about certain aspects of
my costume let's say I was wearing a get
on full body you know jumpsuit or sort
of thing and it's such a new technology
even still oh we've been introduced to
it a lot of different ways sometimes
people wear cameras on their head
sometimes just dots all over their face
they have balls all over their suit the
way that ayalim did it I wore a suit
that was very comfortable it didn't have
all of that restriction on it it was
just had interesting designs on it which
: it was very cool it was like a luge
costume from like the Italian team yeah
I mean it didn't have the colors but
still and then I was on stilts so I was
seven foot one so I towered over
everyone most of the time and and it was
great you know just even at that height
it colors how you move and help me get
into character it was it was fantastic
it was basically just acting but then
the makeup and the costume came later
but because you're on set you are able
to create a character with the other
actors without that you can't tell a
story the true character who can react
in a moment with some of the stuff
Diego's throwing at you you need to be
able to throw it right back and Alan I
think your shortchanging yourself a
little bit too because you stepped into
amazing iconography with robots in Star
Wars and you know when you figure that
c-3po and r2d2 and now bb-8 what was
amazing about what Alan did is he had to
find what that individual sense was
that he could create a another robot in
the family of robots in Star Wars and I
think he definitely did that he's going
to be very memorable I think I think
John NOLA testify to this is that
there's a feeling you can't help it
because it's CGI there's a feeling onset
which is you know if we change our minds
you want to change this performance a
little bit it's in the computer maybe we
can worry about that later
you kept saying that and we shot the
whole thing as if as if k2 was whatever
Allen did on set whatever it was was
exactly what Katie was going to do in
the final film and so you know Katie
would get you know when Allen no offense
but would screw up a few times and we'd
do multiple multiple takes even though
you're thinking I'll get can't you just
animate this stuff and you can't and
what we learn was on the very few
occasions there are times where we
wanted to tweak something we go you know
what just just make me do something a
little bit different to what Allen did
and every single time it didn't work and
and we had to be true to Allen's
performance all the time and even when
we wanted to tweak something we got
Allen back and we recorded him on film
and copied his performance because he is
k2 and a lot of the humor that's in the
film that's really funny it's just this
guy improvising he was given freedom to
do whatever he wanted whenever he wanted
and there are shots we couldn't use
because I sometimes I was holding the
camera and I'm laughing and the camera
is rocking up and down and there's stuff
we can't even talk about it it was
hilarious okay thanks for joining us hi
Neela from Australia Felicity I was
wondering there's a scene in the film
where kassian just has to stand back and
watch Djinn kick its Stormtrooper but
fantastic I wonder how you feel seeing
yourself do that and if the process of
finding Djinn for you was about maybe
finding your inner warrior that you
didn't know you had
yeah well it's engines head it's very
clear
he hates the Empire so anytime she seems
these stormtroopers she has this kind of
very clear instinct to take them down so
so I just hopped into that into
that energy that Jim has and it was I'd
never done that kind of thing before it
was very new the whole kind of physical
preparation that side side of acting I'm
kind of used to lots of you know talking
in corsets so it was really nice to be
running around with them with a blaster
and a baton to bash stormtroopers with
but it was yeah it was an extraordinary
process and you work very closely with
the stunt team who take you through
every kind of move and moment and and
and support you throughout the whole
thing and I'm very lucky to have a great
support from that from the front team
doing it what format was wrote one shot
on and why have you guys chosen the
specific formats that you're shooting
for the new Star Wars movies well when
you I mean we had the difficult task of
we were kind of making a period piece as
well we're making a film that sort of
we'd say to the crew and the designers
like imagine this is set in 1977 and
don't do anything we couldn't have done
back then in terms of aesthetic and that
applied to the camerawork and to some
extent in the prophecy in today's cinema
you know we've got these 4k projections
and things going on night max and and
this brand-new camera had come out from
RE and it was incredible and it's like
four times the resolution of normal film
cameras but Greg the DOP was like okay
this is fantastic but we also want to go
back to the 70s with the analog kind of
look of the movie and so he got hold of
this Panavision lens that's from 17
millimeter animal fur they shot Ben Hur
with this actual lens and for the first
time ever in cinema re who and
Panavision which are two separate
companies in the film history they came
together to make one camera for Star
Wars and it was incredible and the for
those who were technically minded what
the result is you get this very narrow
depth of field so if you're focused on
me the background is quite blurred and
the foreground quite blurred and it was
a nightmare for the focus puller
there was this young guy called Jake and
he performed a miracle because we were
like there was battle scenes we didn't
put marks down we were just running in
there with the camera and he was always
getting the focus we didn't drop any
shot out of the movie because it was
because it was out of focus and and I
think a lot of the beauty in the film is
down to the the cameras that were used
so had that looked of looks like a
modern version of the past you know it
was kind of what we're going for which
is kind of what rode when he's trying to
achieve say that I think what's really
great about the fact that we're now
moving into these standalone movies is
that we're bringing in essentially
auteur directors like Gareth and we're
really supporting those directors in
their vision and we're looking at each
of these movies without a rule book
we're basically saying okay here's a new
story a new movie a new approach what do
we want to do and we're very open to
that and I think it very much is in the
spirit of what George Lucas did to begin
with I mean he inspired ILM innovation
and technological innovation was
extremely important to him and it's very
much a part of the culture of this
company so that's what we we want to
continue yeah I mean it was all
subconscious to some extent we've
watched Star Wars to death like you guys
I think I've seen the opening of the
film most of you know all of you and
it's kind of a reflection of Star Wars
and you hope to some extent and it's
just really a segue so I can get these
guys in because in we went to Iceland to
film the opening scene and it didn't
occur to me till later that when you
think about New Hope you know the very
first time you see the antagonist come
in Darth Vader it's a black guy in a
black cape surrounded by white
stormtroopers and at the opening of a
film there's there's a guy in a white
cape so anyway black stormtroopers and
it's all these subconscious things where
we're trying to take what's familiar but
sort of inverted or twist it and film in
that scene with Ben and Mads I always is
one of the hardest things we've ever
film and people say what's the hardest
thing you ever did I think it was
probably that one because we were free
our pits off out there it was it was and
and the worst thing was this fog was
coming in and then it suddenly disappear
so we set up these amazing shots and
we'd be really excited and then suddenly
there'd be a whiteout you couldn't see
like three meters ahead of you you'd
have to wait and then suddenly it would
clear and and these are like two of the
most incredible actors in the world and
it was just so good to just put them up
against each other and go and let it let
it unfold and Ben Ben is so relaxed in
front of the camera that he would start
like just messing around he's very
playful and I thought he was reciting
Shakespeare or something like to get
himself into character and then I would
listen carefully to the lyrics realize
he was singing Billie Jean by Michael
Jackson then and even like frozen I
think there was like times I did sing a
bit of frost yeah we used to be friends
or whatever that's right yeah yeah yeah
I did that we used to be friends it's
escaping me now but yes I remember it
vividly
Michael adano from The Sydney Morning
Herald in Australia a question for
Gareth and also for Ben the big cameo
here obviously or the big kind of guest
appearance is Darth Vader can you talk a
little bit about working with that
costume how powerful that image is in
cinema and when you are actually actors
honor working film set what happens in
the tipping point between dealing with
an actor in a costume and the fact that
that actor in that costume is is a very
powerful personal cinematic image that
is present in front of you so first the
first thing you you you have to do is
just get over the fact that you're doing
a scene with Darth Vader and that that
takes yeah that that took me a little
while because I am you know I'm a first
generation fanboy so
I was yeah it took a little while to
feel like like I could answer him with
some solidity like we could have a
discussion as it were that that took a
little while and also um Daffy is his
his gestures and his mannerisms are so
familiar that finding someone that can
can execute that in a way that is fluid
is its own skill set and so that that
requires a certain amount of of thought
and consideration to when you're doing
it but you know there was a time Ben I
you know is y'all know Ben's work he's
he's got this ability to be if he wants
to to be incredibly intimidating and and
in turn the entire process making the
film it was a kid in the candy store
where it had amazing time and I kept
thinking I wonder if there'll ever be
this moment where I'll see like some of
the characters he's played or something
to pop out and there was we were in the
middle of filming the same with with
Darth and Ben was like Gareth need to
talk to you and I was like what was the
matters we need to go in the corner and
talk to you I need to have a word and it
was like oh here we go was Amer and we
go over and I'm like you're right Ben
he's like no and it's like what's the
man he goes it's done
and it was like I know and we both had
this little moment where we melted and
we could just admit it and then we
turned around really professionally like
okay we'll try and fix that and we walk
back it's probably still pretty
difficult to simple scene with Darth
Vader and like not turn into a child
again and you can tell he's coming on
set because we we learn a little bit
that we should do the rehearsals and
talk through the scene without the
costume because as soon as that helmet
goes on it's too intimidating you can't
give direction to Darth Vader like you
know he tells you what he's gonna do
and so so but then what happens is you
know it's film set sorry noisy there's a
lot of you know banging and clattering
going on and suddenly just starts to get
quiet and you're chatting to someone and
why is it gone so quiet and hing comes
Darth Vader and he stands on and the
whole crew is just like a five year old
and like this and we all it happens to
everybody and then II think I've gotta
go I'm gonna speak to him and you have
to snap out of it it's um it's it is
it's probably one of the highlights
again to do this film was little members
that and you're very aware of it
everyone that is very aware of it and
you become the most popular person in
the world the day you're filming those
scenes because they you look round and
there's everyone turns out yeah Matt's
your character Galen is kind of a
complicated character because he's not I
mean he does dirt he does you know he's
involved with bad things it's not
necessarily a villain what kind of what
kind of approach do you have to like a
character with that sort of complexity
nobody yeah he said I mean I think that
as actors we always try to find like the
two sides of a character but definitely
it's in this one because he's working
together with this gentleman him
something that he believes from the very
beginning as a project that has the
ability to change the world into a
better place and though be that it turns
out that he's working on something that
he didn't know and and for that reason
he's in a gigantic dilemma and for the
reasons I will not spoil here the
dynamic gets even bigger so yes that's a
great song here as you said you used to
be maybe in the 70s in the 80s anymore
black and white but there are a lot of
Gray's in it
yeah and you again David foreign from
mentor Express I will ask the cast
earlier about their thoughts on their
first action figures I know Matt's
doesn't have one yet but hopefully soon
getting finally their themselves in
plastic form and if Kara could talk
about the score by Michael Giacchino at
all okay we'll start with the action
figures cuz that's always fun
where's you got one right I did get an
action figure he's because I think he's
a lot better looking than I am
they accidentally modeled it on Diego
something easily confused yeah it was a
kind of surreal amazing moment to be
honest I remember kind of playing with
those toys as a kid and so to be part of
that universe you know in plastic is is
an amazing thing
there's no shopping is easy yeah
slightly narcissistic yeah even everyone
like why are you why give me Diego I
thought yeah Michael did an amazing
score for us he's he's a massive massive
massive massive massive massive star
wars fan I think a lot of us compete for
who's the biggest star Wars fan worked
on the film and I'd go around his house
and you walk in the door and and in his
main front room is I don't know how big
but just like it's that big but it's
like 13 foot tall framed poster of a new
hope and sort of joke like oh you didn't
have to do that for us and he's like
nice has been up for like 13 years and
he said he listened to my strikes back
soundtrack to death as a kid and it's
just I think the vocabulary of that
music is in him and and it just poured
out and this stuff I mean you know there
there's particular moments in the film
musically especially towards the end
that is truly stunning and and and very
emotional I think he just knocked it out
the park that we were very lucky
you